opened in time for the World Cup this
new part of Hamad International Airport
has been designed to offer often tired
and stressed out passengers a different
travel experience
the vision is to completely change the
idea of
in the aviation industry for passengers
who are used to come in narrow corridors
dark places where stressed the time they
step their foot into the airport until
they get into their their Ploy this is
what we wanted to change
the main Concourse contains a 6 000
square meter tropical garden it's made
up of 300 trees and 25 000 plants
sourced from sustainable forests in
Malaysia and Thailand in order for the
rainforest to thrive indoors this
building has been designed in a
particular way for example the roof
above me is made out of special glass
which controls and filters the light
surrounding the tropical garden are 65
new shops and restaurants
the main terminal has been expanded by
125 000 square meters and passenger
capacity has increased by nearly 50
percent it's quite significant because
it is raising the capacity of Hamad
International from 40 million to 58
million passengers of course this is not
the ultimate capacity we aim for Hamad
International but we are getting there
very close to what eventual capacity of
over 70 million passengers we envisage
with the final expansion that will start
taking place soon after FIFA
the first passage is to use this part of
the terminal will depart on a flight
from Doha to Kuwait on Friday there are
five new gates in this area airport
authorities say the number of arrivals
and departures from here will increase
steadily in the coming days Victoria
Gayton B Al Jazeera Doha